I'm gonna make you wait and I'm gonna
make you wait because this is a lot to
handle all at once sex on the first date
is that cool like I said is that cool
it's debatable I am for having sex on
the first date if the value is obtaining
a relationship I am against sex on the
first day I'm Pro freedom and I'm Pro
sex on the first day I am against having
sex on the first date if you are feeling
it I am Pro sex on the first date no no
no sex on the first date I think first
dates in general are very performative
but if you get to the point where like
you feel comfortable enough with that
person to have sex with them you should
go for it
why build walls for yourself you're on a
date things are going well and you
engage in healthy normal sex having sex
on the first date it also just nips it
it's right in the butt that hole are we
gonna be compatible in bed question
somebody who wants to have sex on the
first date should do it because they'll
find out that they're incompatible like
I don't think sexual tension just
dissipates after you sex for the first
time I think it does so I think if you
are a heterosexual woman and you are
interested in a guy you should not have
sex with him on the first day it makes
me really sad about that is that its
operating under the assumption like
don't give the boy what he wants because
the boy is terrible and if he gets what
he want he won't want you anymore I
don't think you should go into a first
date thinking you're gonna hook up with
this person tonight I would say to be
open to it if you're feeling it with
someone and you're not gonna have sex on
the first date just because it's the
first date you know I feel like that's
limitation life's too short that person
could be hit by a bus the next day
when you watch a movie and you hear that
there's a really great scene later on in
the movie you don't skip all the setup
and the character development who just
jumps into the scene select goes to the
cool scene watches it and then goes back
to the beginning cuz it a sec screen cuz
I'll jump ahead so first they have a
date kiss a little bit next time you'll
do this sex part of the relationship I
like just building up that like
excitement for it you're looking for a
relationship you're gonna be in a
relationships just slow down once you
like girl relationship with someone in
the sex is better yeah so it could just
get better and better and better all
because you had meaningless sex with
someone one day doesn't mean it can't be
meaningful and even better than next you
can't get to know someone sharing an
entree at Olive Garden if you're making
that decision after two hours then
you're just telling them I just think
you're hot let's essentially masturbate
together
great sex isn't just about having a
physical connection it's about intimacy
and real knowledge of the other person
of their personality just let it all go
just two animals just letting those
instincts overtake you some people can
use their intellect to overpower their
human nature but you can't deny that
human nature exists I think doing what
feels right is typically an OK thing
especially when it comes to first dates
they're pretty performative you're in
control of whether you do or not so at
the end of the day you do have your
power it doesn't make you easy I don't
think anybody deserves me all in one
night to be honest with you
well I 100% believe that I mean you're
someone who like no one could deserve
you ever
these are called nudes can we take some
of those home yeah the guy who doesn't
want to have second first date in these
condoms